In golf,
when it comes to diversity,
it has been honestly
a tough road.
I wanted to put down on paper
what I wanted to look like while I
was on out the golf course, you know,
jeans, sweatshirt,
Cuban link chain
and some sneakers
and even a fitted hat.
And
we're literally <font
color=#FFE400FF>gravitating
people to the game
just
through clothing.
My name is Olajuwon Ajanaku
founder of Eastside Golf
and also a professional golfer.
And I'm
Earl Cooper, co-founder
and also one of the
best young
teachers in America.
A lot of other golf brands
you'll see golf /leisure wear,
where ours is golf /streetwear.
A lot of times people see our logo
and we've been told
they see themselves.
Taking the club back,
chain is swinging one way,
you know, it
represents that I belong.
It represents something I felt golf
has been missing for a long time.
And now we're
growing into a brand
that is truly changing golf.
We have a
wide range of consumers
that go
from an age range of
70-years-old
down to 17-years-old,
men
and women.
And we
feel like that's <font
color=#FFE400FF>just representative
of what the game
really
should be and look like.
And a lot of the pieces actually
live on and off the golf course.
We have boutiques
that are interested in the polos,
but then also, you know, pro shops.
We're
rooted in golf.
We are a golf brand,
but we also
aren't lost in the fact that
there is
so many other people
out here
that don't know the game.
It's designed from a
perspective
of it's a dual use.
It truly is very important
to see representation in the game.
When you look at golf itself,
they sell to golfers.
When we're coming in,
we have the partnerships
with NBA and MLB.
I mean, we're talking to
these other organizations
that truly want to see golf expand.
I would say one of the
challenges that we've had,
since we don't have
an apparel background,
just as far as the
production process,
that's something
that we had to learn.
Being
an entrepreneur,
I don't think
people truly
recognize the fact
of
how difficult it is,
especially
if you're <font
color=#FFE400FF>starting
in the space
where it's
never been done before.
It's not just a
business that
we are just doing to do.
We're
passionate <font
color=#FFE400FF>and we
deeply care about it.
So there's a process
that we
have to maintain as well
and so be
in it for the long haul.
We are hiring right now.
We're looking to scale the business and
double in staff by the end of the year.
I feel like it's going to make
the world of difference
and move our company forward.
One of my favorite
moments, honestly,
when I designed our first Jordan,
our Jordan Retro 4.
It was really hitting off the colors
that I put on the logo itself,
navy, gold, gray and white.
But then also putting
a canvas on the bottom.
It was just a fantastic experience.
I think
also signing our first
athlete,
Wyatt Worthington II.
And the
moments that we've been
able to give
back to Morehouse College,
our
alma mater.
Being able to go
back and
doing a collab with Beats by Dre.
These are just
moments that
for us we dreamed of.
As we
look down the road <font
color=#FFE400FF>with Eastside Golf,
what excites me
the most
is one, the opportunities
that we'll
be able to offer folks,
when it comes to
working
for a young, fresh company
that
are doing real changes.
Also excited to,
you know,
new collaborations,
partners
that we'll be working with.
We're actually going to be now
accessible on video games,
PGA Tour 2K23 and NBA 2K23.
It's going to make our brand
just go so much more further,
you know, and reach
such a younger demographic.
We're not here to make
professional golfers.
We're here to introduce you to the game
so you can use this game as a tool,
because with whatever
you want to do in your life,
this game of golf can help you with that.
For
me, in my own <font
color=#FFE400FF>personal
experience,
I wasn't
always comfortable <font
color=#FFE400FF>on the golf course.
It
wasn't something
that
I immediately loved.
But once
I saw the opportunities
that were
out there, I was like, wow.
And so that
young kid
that is watching this
trust and
believe
that golf can offer you
all the things that
you may
see in other sports,
whether it be
basketball or
football or baseball.
You may just
not know
that they exist,
but
they definitely do.